große Offensive große Zweifel hat die
Ukraine genug Unterstützer das ist unser
Thema heute Abend an diesem Donnerstag
um 22 Uhr guten Abend liebe Zuschauer
eine große Gegenoffensive soll die
Entscheidung für die Ukraine bringen die
Erwartungen sind hoch im Land und bei
den westlichen Verbündeten und
ausgerechnet die liefern immer noch zu
wenig Munition und vor allem keine
Raketen mit größerer Reichweite die für
den Erfolg der Ukraine so notwendig
wären und vom Geheimdienst Verrat in den
us-diensten erfährt der ukrainische
Präsident selenski aus der Zeitung volle
Unterstützung und volles Vertrauen sehen
offenbar anders aus große Offensive und
große Zweifel wir müssen reden mit
diesen Gästen
der Außenminister von Luxemburg Jean
Asselborn
von den Grünen Jürgen Trittin
die zdf-reporterin Katrin Eigendorf
die Politikwissenschaftlerin Janka örtel
der ehemalige US-General Ben hot Chef
und ZDF Korrespondent Elmar t wissen
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner und
die begrüßt alle Gäste dieser Sendung
nochmal ausgesprochen herzlich Kiew
Moskau Washington Den Haag heute in
aller Munde und Joe Biden will es noch
einmal machen
der 80-Jährige hält sich immer noch für
fit genug die freie Welt auf seinen
alten Schultern zu tragen
sein Widersacher Ex-Präsident Donald
Trump verspricht den Wählern wieder das
Blaue vom Himmel
wenn ich Präsident wäre würde ich den
Ukraine Krieg in einem Tag beenden
doch kann sich Europa auf Joe Biden
verlassen im Wahlkampf wird er das wohl
Amerikas höher gewichten als dass der
Ukraine
und das Leck im Pentagon hat Zweifel der
Amerikaner am militärischen Erfolg der
Ukraine aufgedeckt Präsident selinski
ist verbittert
ich bin vorab nicht informiert worden
das ist schlecht und es schadet uns
es ist nicht gut für den Ruf des Weißen
Hauses und es ist nicht gut für den Ruf
der Vereinigten Staaten
der frühere US-General Ben Hodges nennt
es selbst erfüllende Prophezeiung die
US-Administration sagt nicht dass die
Ukraine gewinnen muss was wiederum zu
nur schrittweisen Lieferungen von
militärischen Fähigkeiten führt um
tatsächlich zu gewinnen
und Ben horches ist heute Abend bei uns
der Reihe nach Ben der ukrainische
Präsident wird selbst abgehört und er
erfährt aus der Zeitung das ist diesen
Skandal bei den US-Geheimdiensten
gegeben hat was ist das für ein
Verhältnis ist das ein
Vertrauensverhältnis
das ist natürlich ziemlich peinlich für
die Vereinigten Staaten es ist auch
peinlich für meine Präsidenten aber
diese Beziehung zwischen den Vereinigten
Staaten und der Ukraine reicht so tief
und es gibt so viel was die Vereinigten
Staaten schon getan haben und der
Schaden durch diese nix war im Vergleich
minimal ich glaube das Präsident
selenski durchaus Recht hatte so Arsch
und kritisch zu reagieren aber ich
glaube wir werden weitermachen
die USA müssten weniger am Erfolg der
Ukraine zweifeln und sie mehr
unterstützen warum war und ist die
US-Regierung zögerlich
das größte Problem das mein Präsident
und auch der Bundeskanzler braucht der
britische Premierminister immer kurz
davor halt gemacht haben klar zu sagen
dass wir wollen dass die Ukraine gewinnt
die Aufgabe Nummer 1 für unsere zivilen
politischen
Führungspersönlichkeiten ist klar zu
machen was der Strategie das
strategische Ergebnis sein soll und das
fehlt noch und weil sie dieses Ergebnis
nicht definiert haben führt das dazu
dass wir nur Schritt für Schritt Dinge
anbieten und auch Entschuldigungen
finden dafür warum wir keine Abrams
Panzer oder F16 oder lang Strecken
Raketen liefern können der Schlüssel
liegt darin wirklich zu definieren was
das gewünschte Ergebnis ist und das
Ergebnis sollte natürlich sein dass die
Ukraine gewinnen soll ganz praktisch
zeigt sich dieses Misstrauen darin dass
diese länger reichen den
kurzstreckenwaffen nicht geschickt
werden in die Ukraine die die aber
dringend braucht wenn Sie beispielsweise
die Krim befreien
ich glaube
dass die Bedenken des Weißen Hauses
darüber dass die Ukraine länger also
Langstrecken Raketen gegen Ziele in
Russland verwenden würde dass das
Gegenüber Kiew klargemacht wurde und
präsidente okay die werden wir so nicht
verwenden aber wir brauchen sie trotzdem
um die Krim zu isolieren und unhaltbar
zu machen für die russischen
Streitkräfte und ich glaube dass wenn
Präsident selenski das sagt und die
Ukraine das dann nicht einhalten wird
dass die USA diese Art von Unterstützung
sofort abschalten könnten das ist also
denke ich kein wirklich legitimer Grund
diese Möglichkeiten der Ukraine
vorzuenthalten ich glaube es ist eher
eine Entschuldigung weil die Regierung
nach wie vor nicht entscheiden kann dass
sie wirklich wollen dass die Ukraine
gewinnt Katrin Eugendorf ist bei uns im
zdf-korrespondentin in den
verschiedensten Ländern der Welt aber
und auch vor allen Dingen in der Ukraine
dieses Misstrauen der Amerikaner ist
beschrieben und silensky ist darüber
sehr zornig wenn sie beschreiben müssten
wessen eigentlich größer ist
wie würde ihre wahlausfall wer hat das
größere Misstrauen die US-Amerikaner
gegen die Ukraine oder die Ukraine zu
den Amerikanern sicherlich mit Grund die
US-Regierung und da steht sie ja auch
nicht alleine sondern das ist im Prinzip
ja ein Fakt dass das auch die Europäer
über den Verlauf des Krieges immer
wieder gezeigt haben dass sie der
Ukraine bestimmte Dinge nicht zutrauen
dass sie also sozusagen mal in dem
Verhalten beherztes Eintreten für eine
Sache sieht anders aus als das was wir
im Verlauf des Krieges beobachtet haben
bei den westlichen Partnern der Ukraine
aber natürlich muss man auch sagen
das ist ja eine Situation die Welt vor
eine ganz neue Herausforderung gestellt
hatte das ist ja nie da gewesen seit dem
Ende des Zweiten Weltkrieges ist das ein
Land in der Form mit Waffen unterstützt
wurde das ein nicht NATO Mitglied in der
Form unterstützt wurde von der NATO
diese Zweifel sind schon berechtigt aber
die Ukraine haben im Verlauf des Krieges
immer wieder gezeigt dass die Zweifel
unbegründet waren und haben die Welt ja
überrascht aber dennoch denke ich sind
die Zweifel angebracht und was ich in
der Ukraine sehe es gibt natürlich immer
wieder große Frustration über das
Verhalten und zögerliche Verhalten der
Amerikaner über das Misstrauen an der
Ukraine aber letztendlich wissen die
Ukraine natürlich ganz genau dass die
Vereinigten Staaten und Europa ihre
wichtigsten Verbündeten in diesem Krieg
sind wir werden über Europa natürlich
noch sprechen wir gehen jetzt an dieser
Stelle aber erstmal rasch nach
Washington zum Studioleiter des ZDFs in
Washington MRT wissen immer die
Nachrichten dieses Tages werden wir
gleich noch mal Streifen in dieser
entscheidenden Kriegsphase
so viel
gegenseitiges Skepsis zwischen Kiew und
Washington zu haben
wie bitter ist das glauben sie
ja ich glaube dass die Skepsis gar nicht
so groß ist wie manche momentan
schreiben und denken denn in der Tat ist
es von Beginn an bei diesem Krieg so
gewesen dass sich die Ukraine auch nicht
hat in ihre Karten schauen lassen wie
gut oder wie schlecht man an der Front
aufgestellt ist was man braucht welche
Operation man unternimmt während der
Westen allen voran die Amerikaner doch
sehr weitgehend Geheimdienst
Informationen aufklärungsinformationen
geliefert haben um der Ukraine zu
ermöglichen die richtigen Ziele effektiv
am Ende zu treffen aber es gab in den
letzten Monaten immer Situationen wo man
das Gefühl hatte das hätte man vorher
wissen sollen oder die Ukraine die
Regierung in Kiel hat selber nicht alles
unter Kontrolle will man Beispiel nennen
im August letzten Jahres oder in der
Nähe von Moskau ja Daria dougina die
Tochter eines Nationalisten eines
russischen Nationalisten mit einer
Autobombe getötet ähm da hatte man hier
das Gefühl auch das sei von hier
veranlasst worden das wäre ja ein Schlag
mitten in der russischen Hauptstadt dann
eben gewesen das bestreitet hier man hat
so ein bisschen das Gefühl da sind
einige möglicherweise auf eigene
Rechnungen unterwegs silenski weiß auch
nicht was jeder Teil seines Militärs
seines Geheimdienstes tut und insofern
hat man eben nicht alle Informationen
mit der Ukraine geteilt wie sich
umgekehrt auch nicht gemacht hat
übrigens dass die Pentagon leaks eine
Überraschung für Kiew waren sie waren
auch eine Überraschung fürs Weiße Haus
das Weiße Haus hat ebenfalls eher aus
der Presse erfahren welche Einzelheiten
denn tatsächlich an die Öffentlichkeit
gelangt sind das war Journalisten
Kollegen zu danken weil ein 21-jähriger
nationalgarist offensichtlich vor seinen
Freunden angeben wollte beginnt bei Joe
Biden jetzt eine abseitsbewegung von
Kiew das ist die Frage MRT wir sind auch
weil man sich bald in einem Wahlkampf
gegen Donald Trump befindet
ich glaube das ist noch nicht der Fall
dass seine Absetzbewegung gibt das klare
Signal fast jeden Tag aus dem Weißen
Haus auch von Anthony blinken im
Außenminister ist man steht weiter dicht
an der Seite der Ukraine und will alles
tun um sie auch weiter zu unterstützen
aber man macht glaube ich Kiew sehr klar
dass es Risiken gibt in den nächsten
Monaten vielleicht auch in den nächsten
Jahren weil eben Amerika in einem
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf steckt und
weil möglicherweise ein Kandidat für die
Republikaner Antritt der am Ende bereit
wäre Deals mit Wladimir Putin zu machen
sprich ukrainisches Territorium
herzugeben um irgendwie mal schnell
einen friedensstil zu vermitteln und ich
glaube das Signal setzt man nach Kiew
das Kiew sich überlegen muss was
eigentlich seine Strategie ist wohin es
will und Amerika das weißhaus ist bereit
alles zu tun um die Verhandlungsposition
für Gespräche mit Moskau so sehr zu
verbessern durch Gelände Gewinne durch
Rückeroberung von ukrainischem
Territorium das möglicherweise also auch
Putin an den Punkt kommt wo er bereit
wäre von Maximalforderungen abzurücken
aber das ist nicht in Sicht und deswegen
sagt man den Ukrainern und der
ukrainischen Regierung sehr klar die
Frühjahrsoffensive muss tatsächlich
erhebliche Gewinne bringen und Druck auf
den Kreml erzeugen um im Verlauf dieses
Jahres nach Möglichkeit zu einer Lösung
zu kommen der Druck ist unendlich könnte
man sagen und übrigens auch in Europa
das hat Ben horches schon erwähnt Mister
Europa ist bei uns der Außenminister
luxemburgischer Asselborn müssen die
Ukraine sich jetzt nur wegen Trump
beeilen und möglichst bis zum Herbst
einen so großen militärischen Erfolg
haben oder haben auch das ist nicht
dementiert worden auch Olaf Scholz und
Emmanuel macron Druck gemacht auf
wologenski das ganze möglichst bis zum
Herbst zu beenden sie erinnern sich die
Zuschauer erinnern sich da gab es diese
Geschichte im Wall Street schnell die
ist unter dementiert geblieben
tickt da auch in Europa eine Uhr bei den
Verbündeten also ich glaube ich höre
dass sie sagen aber was ich erlebe in
Europa wir haben jeder Sitzung der
Hausmeister ist die Metro kolleper
beigeschaltet der sagt uns was er
braucht sondern man für Europäer nicht
ja also ich würde man kann von Europa
viel viel Kritik aber wir haben
ausgebildet ein paar tausend Soldaten
wir haben geliefert es sind Panzer auch
Leopard Panzer sind geliefert worden für
die Munition haben wir jetzt 2,5
Milliarden europäische Steuergelder
haben wir die blockiert um dann diese
Munition zu liefern
natürlich ja also das heißt die
Europäische Union finanziert die
Privatindustrie die privat Richtung
Industrie in Europa damit effektiv da
schnell fahren
dann gefragt wie viel Zeit lassen wir
der Ukraine noch also es ist nicht
unsere Aufgabe der Ukraine jetzt mit dem
Chronometer zu sagen was sie machen soll
das ist ein Land das in ein extrem
schwierigen Situation ist und ich glaube
wir haben wir mussten weiter das machen
was für mich jetzt angenommen mit den
Sanktionen mit den
munitionslieferungen und ich bin auch
überzeugt wirklich dass jetzt z.B was in
dem letzten Tag geschehen ist mit dieser
diesen zwei Drohnen das ja eigentlich
die Russen sehr nervös dass sie damit
den Krieg eigentlich motivieren wollen
dass die Menschen in Russland diesen
Krieger überhaupt nicht mehr verstehen
dass sie das wissen sie die Essenz
dieses Regimes Potenz ist der Krieg und
wenn Putin den Krieg verliert ist der
Weg und solange dass ich die andere
Seite solange er da ist wird der Krieg
weitergeführt werden darum wir sollten
keine Bedingungen stellen 20% des
Territoriums sind besetzt von Russland
ich glaube dass die Russen die Ukrainer
in der in dieser Offensive versuchen an
Schwarze Meer zu kommen und wenn sie am
Schwarzen Meer sind haben sie natürlich
ganz andere Möglichkeiten auch was die
Krim angeht aber sehen Sie was geschieht
es gibt sogar Wissenschaftler die sagen
die Offensive hatte schon begonnen sie
sehen die sabotage-aktien die Geschehen
sie sehen diese brennenden tanze kommen
wir gleich nochmal dazu darum würde ich
sagen ich glaube wir sollten auch ein
wenig Vertrauen haben und den Ukrainern
überlassen wie sie ihr Land verteidigen
wir sollen helfen aufgrund von Artikel
51 der Schacher der UNO das ist eine
Koalition wir sind in einer Koalition
damit die Ukraine ihr Land in der
Ukraine verteidigen kann in der UK keine
Verteidigung
wir reden ja sie sagen Vertrauen und wir
fragen jetzt an dieser Stelle Jürgen
Trittin nach dem vorhandenen
Misstrauen
offensichtlich hat Olaf Scholz
tatsächlich auch mit
einen Politiker an der Seite gehabt der
bei diesem langsamen Vorgehen bei dem
bedächtigen vorgehen wie Olaf Scholz ist
formuliert hat
ihn unterstützte oder besser gesagt
genauso auch zögerte wir erinnern uns
Ende Mai 22 gab es einen Namensartikel
von Joe Biden in der New York Times da
hat er schon darauf aufmerksam gemacht
welches die roten Linien der Amerikaner
sind und man hätte ihn vielleicht da
einfach nur genauer zuhören müssen meine
Frage ist glauben Sie dass wir den
Russen momentan jetzt zu viel Zeit
gelassen haben sich in Ruhe einzugraben
in ukrainischen Gebiet
was ich sehe ist dass die Amerikaner im
ganz großen Stil Informationen und
Munition und alles liefern dass die
Deutschen dieses im großen Stil tun ist
für Deutschland eine neue Erfahrung wir
haben wir haben in Europa mit einer
gewissen Verzögerung von einigen Wochen
aber jetzt auch die zweite Milliarde
frei gemacht wir haben die Grundlage
gelegt dass noch mal zu verdoppeln das
ist ja durch die Neuauflage von
Produktionsstätten wir müssen neue
Produktionsstätten schaffen da gibt es
glaube ich wenig dran zu kritisieren das
was oft hat es zu lange gedauert haben
wir haben auch wir Deutschen den Russen
damit Zeit gegeben drei
verteidigungsringe aufzubauen
Verteidigungsminister der Ukraine nach
der Rammstein Konferenz der sagt wir
sind sehr glücklich über das was da ist
wir haben das gekriegt was wir brauchen
und insofern glaube ich das ins anderer
Punkt wichtig ist die an USA in
Deutschland und Europa
sind in dieser Situation in einer Weise
geschlossen wie man sich das vor fünf
sechs Jahren nicht hätte vorstellen
konnten mit einer Ausnahme
aber urban ist eben Opa
[Musik]
weil wenn man das sieht selbstorgan
musste am Ende immer klein beigeben und
der Einstimmigkeit der Ratsbeschlüsse
konnte auf Dauer nicht im Wege stehen
wir sind in der Situation dass alle
justinato auch sagen wir müssen die
Ukraine in ihrer Fähigkeit ihr Gebiet zu
verteidigen auf der Basis Charter der
Vereinten Nation wir tun dies ohne dass
wir selber in eine militärische
Auseinandersetzung mit Russland gehen
das ist der dreizahlack der abgewogen
wird und da fand ich eigentlich beiden
und Scholz relativ nah beieinander ich
hatte fest die kritischste Stimme kommt
von einem US Amerikaner
wir sind bei unserem unbedingt
vorzustellen in den letzten Gast hier
heute in der Runde Janka örtel sie sind
Politikwissenschaftlerin und sinologien
wolle mir sie lensky und der chinesische
Präsidentin haben jetzt endlich
telefoniert und zwar über eine Stunde
lang worauf der ukrainische Präsident
sehr stolz war macht die Ukraine das die
also mit China diesen Kontakt zu suchen
um die Amerikaner ein bisschen
zurückzuärgern oder glauben Sie wirklich
dass die Chinesen eine Vermittlerrolle
spielen könnten also das wird sicherlich
nicht gemacht um die USA zu ärgern das
ist nicht der Punkt wichtig ist dass die
China für die Ukraine wichtiger
Handelspartner ist vor dem Krieg gewesen
ist nach wie vor ein wichtiger
Handelspartner ist und auch nach einem
Krieg ein wichtiger Handelspartner sein
soll und wird das heißt es ist nur
vernünftig auch miteinander im Gespräch
zu bleiben dieser Dialog war etwas was
sich die ukanische Führung lange
gewünscht hat was sehr lange gedauert
hat bis die chinesische Führung dazu
bereit war die ist erst wirklich nach
zwei Jahren jetzt fast dann wieder in
den Kontakten sind also der letzte
Gespräch war glaube ich 21 sonst ist das
letzte Telefonat das heißt das ist schon
wirklich eine bedeutende Schritt gewesen
dass das jetzt so weit gekommen ist es
ist für China ein schwieriger
Drahtseilakt der da momentan zur
Verfügung ist sich darzustellen als
würde man einen Frieden unterstützen als
möchte man Verhandlungen unterstützen es
möchte man dass es zu einer
Konfliktlösung kommt und letzten Endes
aber eigentlich recht fest an Moskau
Seite zu stehen und das zu balancieren
das ist gar nicht einfach für die
chinesische Wirkung derzeit dazu werden
sie uns noch mehr erzählen aber
offensichtlich war es ja ein großes
Bedürfnis von selensky durchaus auch
wertzuschätzen welche Rolle bisher die
Chinesen da in der Öffentlichkeit auch
mit ihrer Friedensinitiative erstmal
gespielt haben ja das ist glaube ich
auch wichtig zu sagen man sollte nichts
unversucht lassen aus ukrainischer
Perspektive ist total verständlich dass
ein Partner der möglicherweise
irgendeine Art und Weise Einfluss auf
Moskau ausüben kann auch wenn man das
nicht überbewerten sollte dass man den
zumindest mit dem Gespräch bleibt das
ist das Mindeste was man tun kann und
man kann es versuchen und ich glaube
niemand kann einer Führung in der
Ukraine momentan vorwerfen wollen jeden
Versuch so auszuprobieren nichts
unversuch zu lassen ich glaube wir sind
in der Situation angekommen in der
Situation so katastrophal ist dass jeder
Versuch es wert ist versucht zu werden
klar und man ja auch verstehen muss dass
es durchaus wirtschaftliche
Verbundenheit bei der Länder gab die
lang und erfolgreich war und insofern
Freundschaftsvertrag und nach wie vor
eine strategische Partnerschaft zwischen
den beiden Staaten
zusammen ich glaube china hat ein ganz
großes Problem sie haben nämlich zwei
nur schwer vereinbare Interessen das
eine Interesse ist dass sie auf gar
keinen Fall wollen das Russland die
stabilisiert wird und Putin stürzt
das wollen sie sich gerne erhalten sie
haben auch Interesse an der billigen
Tankstelle Russland und das ist ja
billiger geworden auch durch unsere
Sanktion und auf der anderen Seite haben
Sie das Problem das geht weit über die
Ukraine hinaus dass dieser Krieg dazu
führt dass bestimmte Lieferketten und
damit produktionsinteressen und
wachstumsinteressen bei ihnen gestört
wird und das lässt sie in dieser Form so
ja so so so schillernd oszillierend
agieren nämlich auf der einen Seite zu
sagen sie wollen dass dieser Krieg
beendet wird das ist das eine Interesse
für dich in sogar abnehmen und auf der
anderen Seite in wieder fest zu Putin zu
stehen die Lämmer in dem sich der
chinesische Politik anrichten Sache die
man sagen muss zu China china hat mit
Brasilien und mit Indien letzte Woche
auf der UNO ein Text gestimmt eine
Resolution wo gesagt wird also sitzt in
Text verbunden mit dem Europarat dass
die Aggression
zu verurteilen ist Aggression also der
Russen in der Ukraine zu werden das ist
das erste Mal dass auf der UNO das
stimmt wurde Verurteilung gewesen das
ist glaube der wichtige Punkt das war
keine Aggression wurde aber trotzdem
hingestellt aber ich glaube der wichtige
Punkte daran war es war eben keine
Resolution direkt über die Ukraine meine
weiteren das ist ein gutes Spiel auch es
macht nämlich genau diese Diskussionen
aus wo stehen Sie eigentlich weil
Botschafter der chinesische Botschaft ja
durchaus auch die ehemaligen Republiken
angezweifelt hat in ihrer Existenz also
man merkt auch dass da Seiten ein
bisschen doppelbeind gespielt wird
kommen wir vielleicht noch mal zurück zu
den militärischen Fragen und da können
sie uns mit der Auskunft helfen wie sehr
es wirklich eine Zusammenarbeit zwischen
Moskau und China gibt auch in
militärischer Hinsicht das ist immer mal
behauptet worden wissen wir denn
mittlerweile ob die Chinesen die Russen
militärisch unterstützen was wir wissen
es ist eine ganz enge militärische
Kooperation gibt seit Jahren schon dass
wir auch jetzt gerade wieder den
chinesischen Verteidigungsminister für
Tage in Russland hatten dass wir bei den
Gesprächen die den Pin geführt hat in
Russland viele ja Teile des
militärischen industriellen komplexes am
Tisch sitzen hatten von der russischen
Seite dass dort über die Frage
langfristiger militärischer
Zusammenarbeit gesprochen worden ist es
geht um langfristige auch technologische
Kooperation und dann geht es um ganz
viele Dinge die wir so nicht ohne
weiteres nachweisen können also wer
liefert hier eigentlich an wen ähm wo
geht etwas über dunkle Kanäle über
illegale Kanäle das können wir so
momentan nicht belegen was wir sehen
können ist das was China liefert ist zum
Beispiel
Körperpanzerung oder Halbleiter es ist
sind alles Güter die sagen dem
Kriegsverlauf jetzt nicht direkt als
Militärgüter dienen aber die durchaus
dazu beitragen dass die
Kriegsmaschinerie am Laufen bleibt und
der wirtschaftliche Kontakt hilft
natürlich die russische Wirtschaft zu
stabilisieren die Spekulation bleiben da
im Raum dass das über Nordkorea und über
den Iran längst passiert MRT wir sind in
Washington wir müssen über diesen
Drohnenangriff reden der über dem Kreml
gestern am frühen Tag und gar nicht erst
am Abend auf Schienen zwei Drohnen was
sagt Washington dazu ist das Fake News
also Washington sagt ganz klar dass eine
Lüge aus Moskau dass man eine
Verantwortung von Washington dahinter
sieht das Washington vorher davon
gewusst habe dass es gewissermaßen
diesen Angriff befohlen habe das wird
hier zurückgewiesen Kiew tut ja genau
dasselbe es trägt keine Verantwortung
dafür sagt jedenfalls die Regierung in
Kiew das passt glaube ich zu dem was ich
vorhin schon mal erwähnte dass hier so
ein bisschen der Verdacht besteht dass
da vielleicht noch andere Akteure am
Werk sind sei es aus Russland selber
also russischer Widerstand sei es
vielleicht auch Ukrainer die ich sag mal
separat vom Regierungsapparat in Kiew
unterwegs ähm sind da gibt es auch ein
paar Verdachtsmomente aber alles pure
Spekulation ich will eins noch mal sagen
zu China wenn ich darf und zwar sagt man
hier in Washington mittlerweile auch ist
doch gut wenn China Ping mit äh volume
mir selenski telefoniert erstens kriegt
er da mal die Opferperspektive mit und
hört nicht immer nur die
Täterperspektive aus Moskau und zweitens
ist das was als Friedensplan ja
bezeichnet wird von vor einigen Wochen
aus China ja gar kein Friedensplan
sondern das ist im Grunde genommen so
eine Aufzählung von ich sag mal
Allgemeinplätzen wenn man es
freundlicher ausdrücken würde während es
Prinzipien und die sind zum Beispiel
Einhaltung der Karte der Vereinten
Nationen also Integrität Souveränität
und die Unverletzlichkeit des
Territoriums der Ukraine und wenn China
bereit wäre so hat Anthony blinken diese
Woche gesagt seinen Einfluss gelten zu
machen dass Moskau diese Prinzipien auch
anerkennt wunderbar dann ist China als
Verhandlungspartner gerade mal recht
oder als Vermittler damit man eben doch
Wladimir Putin so unter Druck setzt dass
er doch bereit wäre
faszinieren dieses zu China zu hören ich
versuche zum zweiten Mal zurückzukehren
zu sehen militärischen Fragen noch mal
kurz zum Drohnenangriff bennox ist das
ist auch in ihren Augen
ein Täuschungsmanöver der Russen oder
würden Sie sagen das ist noch offen das
weiß man noch nicht genau
ist wahrscheinlich
die bestgeschützte Einrichtung des
Planeten gegen Raketenangriffe
Drohnenangriffe und als ich mir die
Videos angeschaut habe wie sie alle
wahrscheinlich gesehen haben vergangenen
Abend
da wurde doch klar dass das keinen
Schlag war der das Ziel hatte den Kreml
zu vernichten oder Präsident Putin zu
töten das ist wahrscheinlich ein Versuch
das Krems und auch ein ziemlich ja
schwach ausgeführt dafür versucht um
Russland hier als Opfer darstellen zu
können denn die Menschen können dann
sagen wir müssen zurückschlagen und es
gab so viele Probleme in Russland in den
vergangenen ja eigentlich über die
gesamte Dauer des Krieges und die
Antwort die Reaktion auf diese Drohne
Attacke war zu schnell zu vorbereitet
und passte nicht zum ganzen Rest
natürlich ist das erst einmal eine
Peinlichkeit für Präsident Putin aber
ich glaube das ist ein Zeichen dafür wie
schlecht Dinge stehen dass er will uns
ist sich mit so etwas
auseinanderzusetzen um dann die
Unterstützung aus seinen eigenen
Bevölkerung weiterhin sicherstellen zu
können ich glaube das ist vielleicht
die Möglichkeit gibt dass das ein Ja ist
also dass da Leute intern beteiligt
waren weil Leute es gibt die das gerne
sehen wird also gregorien beispielsweise
die andere auch ja demütigen wollen das
würde mich jetzt gar nicht überraschen
und es ist wirklich überraschend zu
sehen dass es innerhalb der russischen
Führungsebene so viel inkoordins gibt
und so viel Streit und das sieht davon
abhält ein kohärentenplan zu verfolgen
er hat auch sofort dementiert und
trotzdem haben die Ukraine sich gefreut
Kathrin Eigendorf
tatsächlich ist es ja so oder so eine
Blamage für Putin
also das Kiez sich darüber gefreut hat
liegt eigentlich auf der Hand dass die
Ukraine sich gefreut hat liegt
eigentlich klar auf der Hand weil
es zeigt ja die ganze Konzeptlosigkeit
der russischen Führung also was wir
erleben von an Beginn dieses Krieges ist
ja ein permanenter Versuch
ja die Ziele zu erreichen ohne Erfolg
also was haben die Russen nicht alles
versucht und sie sind auf ganzer Linie
gescheitert ich halte die Version dass
das ein ein vom Kreml inszenierte Akt
war eigentlich für die plausibelste wir
wissen es nicht aber das sagen wir passt
gut in das narrativ mit dem Putin ja
versucht diesen Krieg der russischen
Bevölkerung im Prinzip schmackhaft zu
machen das narrativ das nämlich Russland
bedroht ist und was könnte denn nun mehr
bedroht sein als diese sakrosante Figur
des russischen Führers nämlich Putins
also von daher
plausibel halte ich das ich halte das
letzte Variante an Jürgen Trittin sie
wegen mit dem Kopf bisher Schienen ja
persönliche Angriffe sowohl als auf
silensky als auch auf Putin eher
irgendwie nicht unbedingt auf dem Zettel
zu stehen ist das jetzt ist da jetzt ein
Tabu gebrochen glaube ich bin eher beim
Ben Hodges dass wir hier möglicherweise
etwas erleben was aus dem Inneren macht
Zirkel des Kreml kommt für eine
Inszenierung war sie zu idiotisch
inszeniert
erst zu erzählen westliche wahrnehmigung
erst zu erzählen gerade aus russischer
Wahrnehmung es erzählen das waren die
Ukrainer dann feststellen oh sollen wir
den Ukrainern eigentlich zugestehen dass
sie so gut sind dass sie den krämme und
damit Putin angreifen können und dann
haben sie gesagt das waren die
Amerikaner also da glaube ich eher aber
das sind alles Vermutung von der
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir hier eine
Auseinandersetzung innerhalb des macht
separates erleben und prigoshi hat sich
ja eine ganze seit Wochen beschwert er
sich darüber dass er nicht genug
Material kriegt dass er hier das eine
Katastrophe drohe das hat er vorgestern
noch mal erzählt also das sind all diese
Dinge die das zumindest ich sag mal
vorsichtig wie spekulieren alle nicht
ausgeschlossen scheinen dass wir hier
ist zu zeigen mit Signalen zu tun haben
die innerhalb des Machtapparates gesetzt
werden wir sind dann bei den Dingen die
tatsächlich geschehen und auch auf dem
Schlachtfeld tatsächlich geschehen es
gibt immer mehr Angriffe der Ukraine auf
russisches Territorium MRT wissen wir
sind noch mal in Moskau nicht in Moskau
sondern in Washington mit dieser Frage
und wollen aber wissen das was die
Ukraine da tun
Züge versorgungszüge anzugreifen
öldepots anzugreifen sind die im Wissen
und ihn kenn tnis der
US-Administration jetzt im Gange oder
entziehen sich diese
Nadelstiche auf russischem Territorium
Washingtons Kenntnis
ich glaube dass Washington keine
Kenntnis davon hat weil Washington sehr
klar gemacht hat bei mehreren Vorfällen
im letzten Jahr als zum Beispiel
russische
Militärbasen angegriffen wurden auf
russischem Boden eben auch durch
ukrainische Kräfte dass das eigentlich
nicht akzeptables man will keine
Ausdehnung dieses Krieges und schon gar
nicht den Eindruck erwecken dass der
Westen und allen voran die USA in
irgendeiner Weise direkt damit
verwickelt wären und deswegen glaube ich
gehört dass zu diesen Karten die volume
mehr silenski keine Verbündeten
gegenüber auf den Tisch legt was davon
tatsächlich geplant ist und und was dann
ausgeführt wird auch der Angriff
beispielsweise auf die Brücke die zu
Krim führt und ähnliches fällt in diese
Kategorie und ich glaube das ist auch
der Grund weshalb die USA in den letzten
Wochen doch sehr zurückhaltend noch
waren diese Raketen größerer Reichweite
zu liefern oder auch Kampflugzeuge zu
liefern aber beides das muss man klar
sagen wird auch hier nicht
ausgeschlossen man will jetzt einmal
sehen ob mit dem was gel Antwort wurde
die Ukraine in der Lage ist erfolgreich
Territorium zurückzuerobern und wenn es
dann notwendig wird um beispielsweise
die Nachschubwege der Krim
abzuschneiden um damit eben den
entscheidenden Druck zu erzeugen auf
Wladimir Putin dann würde man so etwas
auch liefern beispielsweise
Kampfflugzeuge hier sind in den USA in
Texas bereits mehrere ukrainische
Piloten in Simulatoren für F16
Kampfflugzeuge ausgebildet worden noch
nicht am Gerät selber aber man hat den
Eindruck dass das relativ schnell
möglich wäre wenn es an den Punkt kommt
dass es notwendig ist aber wie absurd
wenn ich das so fragen darf dass ich die
Ukraine erst beweisen müssten also nicht
nur Ben horche ist sondern etliche
Militärexperten sagen und die Ukrainer
selbst dass dieser Krieg entschieden
werden wird um den Status der Kim warum
muss das ukrainische Militär warum muss
diese administration in Kiew erst
beweisen dass das ein wichtiges
militärisches Ziel ist wenn ich das
Wichtigste
ich glaube das ist eben der disconnect
zwischen dem was man in Washington mit
allen Mittel versucht eben nicht
wirklich hineingezogen zu werden im
Sinne dass Moskau das narrativ aufmachen
kann das Amerika letztlich Russland
direkt angreift oder die NATO
Verbündeten die es tun und deswegen ist
das eigentlich das gleiche Prinzip das
in den letzten 12 15 Monaten gegolten
hat dass man immer nur Stück für Stück
das liefert von dem man sich verspricht
dass es den entscheidenden Druck erzeugt
dass Putin von seinen Maximalforderungen
abrückt die ähm der Mut ist nicht groß
genug in Washington aber auch nicht in
Europa nicht groß genug um zu sagen wir
müssten jetzt eben das tun was benennen
wie ich finde zu Recht sagt man müsste
eben jetzt das liefern was möglichst
schnell die entscheidenden Gewinne für
die Ukraine erzielt damit es dann auch
schneller zu einem möglichen Gespräch
oder oder Verhandlungen kommen kann wir
sind dankbar für alles was wir von
mrtiven gehört haben hier heute Abend
und sagen Danke nach Washington und sind
genau wenn horches bei dieser Frage sind
die Nadelstiche Vorbereitung schon eine
offensive oder sind sie erstmal der
versucht Terrain zu machen und zu
verunsichern
Angriffe auf die öl-infrastruktur
beispielsweise diesen tiergeschehen an
der Peripherie der Ukraine
und das ist eine ganz klassische
ja Strategie der Unterbrechung der
feindlichen Logistik bevor man selbst
eine offensive beginnt ich habe mir
heute eine Landkarte angeschaut und da
sieht man wo diese Angriffe
stattgefunden haben das ist tatsächlich
eine ja ein wirklich gute Vorgehensweise
das zeigt auch wie gut der ukrainische
generalstaat aufgestellt ist um
Unterbrechung hier zu erzwingen um auch
die russischen Streitkräfte dazu zu
zwingen zu reagieren und wenn die
Ukraine dann den physischen Teil ihrer
Offensive begonnen haben nun ich würde
das auch nicht unbedingt Nadelstiche
nennen das ist er die Art und Weise wie
man mit Präzision Masse besiegen kann
wenn man bestimmte Ziele trifft die sehr
lohnenswert sind und großen Schaden
anrichten dann kann man den Vorteil der
Russen digitalisieren nämlich ihre Masse
wir haben vor 14 Tagen den deutschen
Verteidigungsminister hier in der
Sendung gehabt und er hat sehr offen und
sehr klar bestätigt dass Dinge diese Art
nicht nur notwendig sondern durchaus
auch legitim sind ein bisschen anders
hörte sich das dann beim deutschen
Bundeskanzler an es ist
selbstverständlich und völlig normal in
so einer Auseinandersetzung einer
militärischen das auch der Angegriffene
ins gegnerische Territorium vorgreift
vorgeht um beispielsweise Nachschub Wege
zu unterbinden das ist das normalste der
Welt
wir haben den ich habe einen Fehler
gemacht merke ich gerade weil ich Ihnen
einen ausführlicheren zeigen wollte an
dem auch noch mehr werden dürfte
ehemalige Präsident zu hören ist der
automatisch Berlin und Boris Pistorius
dann drohte unser sagte der
Bundesverteidigungsminister möge sich
daran erinnern das russische Panzer
zuletzt in Berlin standen und dann sagt
der Bundeskanzler das es niemals dazu
kommen sollten dass deutsche Waffen auch
russisches Territorium erreichen und das
eben ein Krieg zwischen der Nato und
Russland unbedingt zu vermeiden ist das
ist auch so eine Grauzone und
offensichtlich eine Unterstellung dass
die Ukraine Vorhaben könnten viel weiter
in das russische Territorium zu
erreichen Fragezeichen
genau gar keine Motivation für Kiew nach
Russland hineinzugehen sie haben ganz
klar gesagt dass sie ihr Territorium
verteidigen wollen und Deutschland
Großbritannien Frankreich die
Vereinigten Staaten alle Nationen die
sie unterstützen dass die sich
zurückziehen würden wenn die Ukraine
weiter vorstoßen würde und beschließen
würde dann auch nach Russland
vorzustoßen also die Leoparden die
abbrems die Marder wenn die in Russland
tatsächlich eines Tages stehen sollten
nein das ist ein tatsächlich keine
wirklich mögliche Vorstellung eine
andere Frage ist aber warum erlauben wir
es Russland nach wie vor ihre
Schutzbereiche zu haben sie starten
Raketen gegen zivile Gebäude sie töten
unschuldige Zivilisten in der Ukraine
aber wir verurteilen Kiew wenn eine
Drohne gestartet wird gegen einen
öldepot ich glaube alles in allem
wirklich beeindruckend gezeigt hat
welche Disziplin sie haben und sich
zurückgehalten haben wenn es darum geht
jedes Mal zurück zu schlagen nein sie
sind fokussiert geblieben haben sich
konzentriert und das ist ganz wichtig
für die Befreiung der
kreditsrainer eben genau diese
weiterreichenden
Kurzstreckenraketen nicht noch fehlt
ihnen auch Munition und ihnen fehlen
Tanks und bis dahin sterben weiter viele
ukrainische Soldaten am Boden ja das ist
die Situation da soll man nicht drumrum
reden ich sage nur anders als in der
öffentlichen Wahrnehmung gelegentlich
gemacht wird es ist relativ viel
passiert und ich habe ja bewusst vorhin
in ukrainischen Verteidigungsminister
zitiert und was Boris Pistorius gesagt
hat hat eigentlich eine
Selbstverständlichkeit ausgesprochen die
Außenministerin war ja in der Nähe von
chakiff
der ist die vorwandzeit für Luftangriffe
wenige Minuten weil es so nah an der
Grenze ist und man muss schon tiefen
Respekt vor der Ukraine haben dass sie
in der Form bisher sehr zurückhaltend
waren und jetzt gezielt solche
versorgungslogistik anzugreifen das kann
und will ich ihnen überhaupt nicht
vorwerfen an dieser Stelle aber sie
wissen den Druck verstehen unter der
diese Regierung ist dass sie weiß wenn
sie solche Luft Attacken früher
unterbinden könnte das aber nicht tut
weil sie eben nicht auf russisches
Gebiet gehen will dann gibt es auch für
die ukrainische Regierung ein
legitimations Problem Eigendorf wie groß
ist ihre Hoffnung dass auch der Atem der
Ukraine
kürzer werden könnte dass dieses Volk
dass dieses Militär dass diese Führung
auch anders Ende ihrer
nicht politischen aber militärischen und
menschlichen Möglichkeiten kommt also
das sich durchaus auch als einen
wichtigen Faktor den wir einfach im
Blick haben müssen dieser Krieg trifft
ja vor allem die ukrainische
Zivilbevölkerung und was ich merke
im Verlauf wo ich immer wieder in der
Ukraine war dass die Bereitschaft diese
Opfer weiter so lange zu tragen doch in
gewissen Teilen der Bevölkerung abnimmt
ja also sicherlich ist es so dass noch
die große Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
hinter der Politik selenskys steht aber
man merkt in ganz ganz vielen Bereichen
die Menschen wollen zurückkehren in die
Gebiete die sie verlassen mussten gerade
im Osten der Ukraine sie wollen nicht
dauerhaft als Flüchtlinge irgendwo in
Europa oder auf der Welt verteilt sein
es wird auch schwierig noch weitere
Ressourcen an Soldaten bereitzustellen
die in diesen Krieg ziehen werden da ist
die Ukraine schon an einem Limit
angelangt also vor diesem Hintergrund
wird selenski und wird auch das Militär
ganz sicher unter dem Druck stehen und
steht unter dem Druck diesen Krieg
möglichst bald zu beenden wir sind bei
der großen Frage ob dann auch die Jets
erst kommen wenn die Offensive
eigentlich schon vorbei
ich will etwas sagen zu den
zu den
Operationen also ja das war wirklich
wichtig zu sagen sie wissen dass wenn
man Krieg gesagt hat in Russland
riskiert man Gefängnis das sieht dann
Spezial Operation hat Putin gesagt und
ich bin über der Überzeugung dass jetzt
was die Ukrainer machen zeigen was
spezialoperationen sind und sie machen
die zu 90% auf ihrem Territorium die
Krim gehört zu der Ukraine und die die
Frage ist warum will ich sagen dass Sie
das Recht haben sich auf ihrem für die
verteilen so einzurichten wie sie das
Fürchten finden und sie machen das mit
spezialoperationen
sollte man glaube ich den Unterschied
auch
dann zu den wir dürfen wir dürfen doch
nicht so so kritisch sein und so wir
haben so viel glaube ich trotzdem
versucht nicht nur versucht sondern auch
gemacht für die Ukraine und die Ukraine
ist wir Trittin gesagt hat auch dankbar
dafür wir müssen ja aufpassen dass wir
sie haben nichts bekommen von der
Slowakei und auch von Polen
es werden Piloten ausgebildet in anderen
Ländern ich glaube nicht dass morgen 35
geliefert werden in die Ukraine das ein
ein Pilot braucht ein Jahr um einen 35
fliegen zu können all das glaube ich
darf man jetzt nicht sagen wenn es
stockt dann dieses Fall die Europäer
oder weil die weil der Weste nicht
schnell genug
sagen wir mal militärische
Mittel zur Verfügung gestellt hat
bleiben wir geschlossen in der
Europäischen Union bleiben wir
geschlossen in der NATO die Nato hat
über 100 Panzer geliefert die Amerikaner
haben gesagt
was ist denn realistisch in ihren Augen
oder das realistischee in ihren Augen
wird es gelingende Asselborn die Krim
zurückzuholen wird es gelingen das
gesamte besetzte Gebiet zurückzuholen
und wird es gelingen
Friedensverhandlungen zu beginnen oder
das ist am besten alles drei andere
Frage also zuallererst müssen wir
aufpassen dass im Moment 20% des
Territoriums
besetzt sind so zweitens solange Putin
diese Einstellung hat dass er wie jetzt
vor ein paar Tagen Bahnhof für
bombardiert Kaufhäuser bombardiert kann
man ja nicht daran denken dass dann in
der Ukraine der Gedanke aufkommt jetzt
setzen wir uns zusammen und schließen
einen Frieden darum zur Zeit ist es so
dass wir mit den Sanktionen mit den
kartoffellieferung wenn man Kollege bei
uns ist dann sagt er ich würde das aus
mit der lieber über diplomatische
Lösungen reden also über Munitionen wenn
ich zu ihnen komme das einzige was ich
frage ist Munition Munition Munition
aber das ist wichtig dass die Ukraine
wenn es einmal aufgeht denn jeder kriegt
wird ja sagt man einmal das dann auch
die Ukraine in einer guten Position ist
dann kommt die Creme also ich glaube wir
haben überhaupt keine Ursache keine
Ursache was jetzt geschehen ist nach dem
24 und das die Ukraine nicht das
Territorium ist was ja praktisch auch
von 99% der Lehrerin der Welt anerkannt
wird wissen sie sogar china hat nicht
anerkannt das ist richtig ist also
genau es ist auch noch mal wichtig
festzuhalten dann würden sie also sagen
das heißt und bedeutet die Ukraine muss
gewinnen sie muss hier und
Entschuldigung muss die Krim
zurückkriegen
darf glaube ich die Ukraine nicht
verlieren wenn du keine verliert und
puste ihn gewinnt dann steht
vor Polen und ich glaube das einzige das
müssen wir auch sagen das glaube ich den
Menschen Sicherheit gibt jetzt sehen wir
einen Schweden und Finnland ist die Nato
und ich bin kein Heil begeisterter
Mensch immer gewesen von der Nacht aber
das ist aber die der einzige Schirm die
einzige Garantie die wir den Menschen
geben können ich glaube nicht dass Putin
einmal die NATO angreift ich will doch
interessant zu China glaube China ein
wichtiger ein wichtiger Punkt gemacht er
hat nee china hat das Veto eingelegt bei
Putin gegen die Benutzung von Atomwaffen
und das glaube ich kann nur ein Land wie
China fertig übrigens das bringt
vielleicht kein anderes Land der Welt
vielleicht will er die aber ja auch gar
nicht einsetzen der Vladimir Putin und
wir sind jetzt bei der Frage bennoxes
wir müssen das Verstehen diese Offensive
hat einen eine irrsinnige Bedeutung
hinter ihr steht ein irrsinniger Druck
was glauben Sie was glaubt wenn hosches
wird die Ukraine in diese Offensive
schaffen können
daran liegt die Krim zu isolieren also
die russischen Verteidigungslinien zu
durch geringen bis zum Asowschen Meer
und damit die Isolation der Creme zu
beginnen und dann mehr lang
streckenfähige Präzisionswaffen an den
Start zu bringen damit die ähm auch
unhaltbar wird für die russischen
Streitkräfte
die im Augenblick noch auf der Halbinsel
der kriegen sind also die
Schwarzmeerflotte beginnt schon damit
sich zurückzuziehen weil es diese Sorge
gibt und ich glaube das ist die Art und
Weise wie die Ukraine dieses Jahr
vielleicht sogar bis zum Ende des
Sommers es schaffen könnte die Krim zu
befreien der Don Bass das kommt später
Armut das ist im Augenblick nicht von
strategischer Bedeutung aber wenn die
Ukraine es schaffen sollte auch alle
Kräfte um bachmut herum zu bewegen das
würde im Augenblick nichts ändern aber
die Befreiung der Krim
von Südflanke und eine Möglichkeit zu
schaffen die Creme abzusperren heißt das
auch wenn ich sie richtig verstehe
binhoch ist das für einen dann möglichen
Frieden der Westen akzeptieren würde
dass Teile von Don jetzt und Johannes an
Russland fallen
was ich sage ist das nachdem die Krim
befreit worden ist ich nicht glaube das
ist im Kremlin noch viel Enthusiasmus
für die Vorstellung gibt die ärmeren
Regionen doch jetzt und Johannsen
behalten zu wollen aber ich sage das
kommt halt später die Krim ist wirklich
entscheidend weil die Ukraine nie sicher
sein wird solange russische Streitkräfte
sich dort aufhalten das ist wie ein
Deutsch der im Bauch der Ukraine steckt
und wir wissen dass auch die großen
Investoren die größten Investoren sich
nicht am Wiederaufbau der Ukraine
beteiligen werden wenn Sie glauben dass
Russland wieder angreifen könnte
vielleicht in nur wenigen Jahren die wir
versuchen zu verstehen warum sagt auch
David patrius dass wir dass die
US-Amerikaner zu vorsichtig um nicht zu
sagen über vorsichtig waren also für
unser Verständnis und für Ihr
Verständnis wenn das so entscheidend ist
und wenn sie recht haben mit ihrer These
dass auch die Zukunft Europas und
wahrscheinlich der Welt davon abhängen
warum sind wir dann immer noch zögerlich
ich hätte eine Antwort auf diese Frage
aber die
US-amerikanische Regierung macht sich
natürlich Sorgen um eine mögliche
russische Eskalation und die mögliche
Verwendung einer Nuklearwaffe ich glaube
es gibt die Sorge aber die ist
vielleicht ein wenig übertrieben aber
das mag ein Teil der Erklärung sein ein
weiterer Teil ist dass ich daran glaube
dass China hier eine Rolle spielt
China ist da in der Kommunikation auch
mit der Regierung ich weiß das natürlich
nicht tatsächlich aber ich glaube das
könnte ein Grund sein warum diese
entsprechenden Regierung dann nicht sich
im durchdringen können zu sagen wir
wollen dass die Ukraine bedeutet das ist
und das so steht das Gegenüber und das
muss man glaube ich ganz klar
anerkennen China versucht sozusagen die
Stimme der Vernunft zu spielen gerade
die Stimme Vernunft zu sein man muss
doch vernünftig sein einen
Verhandlungstisch lernen die Punkte die
Wissen angesprochen hatte aus dem zwölf
Punkte Wahnsinn aber natürlich auch
nicht alle Punkte sondern da steht auch
ganz viel drin zum Ende des
kaltkriegsdenkens dass man endlich
ablegen sollte da ist ganz viel Attacke
gegen den Westen auch dabei es geht vor
allen Dingen um unilaterale Sanktionen
die ganz dringend aufgehoben werden
sollen die würden doch niemanden
weiterführen dass ich dabei muss es auch
ein bisschen in der Gesamtheit
betrachten es ist tatsächlich diese
Balance die versucht wird hier aber die
chinesische Position ist ganz klar man
hat nicht umsonst eine sehr enge
Partnerschaft mit Russland die über den
Krieg enger geworden ist und ich glaube
das ist auch in der Dynamik ganz wichtig
nachzuvollziehen noch mal man hätte zu
jedem Zeitpunkt historisch nicht immer
gut leiden in der Tat ganz vorsichtig zu
sagen
meine Partnerschaft ich meine wenn man
sich anguckt du hast was das Verhältnis
zwischen Russland und China heute ist
kann man da nicht von Partnerschaft
reden sondern im Prinzip ist Russland
abhängig von China geworden in einer
Form und das ist das glaube ich was man
von der Dynamiker sehen muss und das ist
gut für Chinas Sicherheitsinteressen
1920er Jahren nicht so wenige Soldaten
an der an der russische chinesischen
Grenze wenn man sich überlegt dass China
immer von Russland überfallen wurde dann
ist das gut wenn Russland schwächer ist
aber vor allen Dingen wenn man auch
einen guten Draht hat zu dem Führer der
dort vor Ort ist und wenn man Stabilität
gewährleisten kann
der Europäischen Union ist China
Amerika und China und Franz in
Deutschland ist es der größte bilaterale
Handelspartner
wir sind bei einer sehr engen
wirtschaftsbeziehung die offensichtlich
eben auch macron noch mal thematisieren
wollte als er jüngst ausgerechnet in
China war das waren im Übrigen für diese
Situation in der sich die Welt findet
natürlich auch dramatische Sätze dass
Frankreich das Europa gerne möchte dass
wir nicht zu versalen oder Mitläufer der
US-Amerikaner werden kommen wir auch
gleich noch mal ich wollte einmal nach
Peking und der
chinesischen Sicht auf diesen kommenden
Frieden schauen was wäre für China denn
akzeptabel außer der Wunsch das Wladimir
Putin möglichst das Jahr 2024 noch im
Amt erleben möge ja es geht um die
Lösung in der Ukraine die Stabilität in
der moskau ist wichtig die Stabilität
Russlands ist wichtig welches
Territorium die Ukraine an Russland
dafür abgeben muss das glaube ich kann
man aus Peking sehr pragmatisch sehen
denn man wird gute Beziehungen
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen danach wieder
aufbauen können es geht vor allen Dingen
auch darum dass man eine Rolle im
infrastrukturaufbau danach hat das sind
die Dinge die da wo man Interesse daran
hat es gibt durchaus Schulden die
Ukraine Vorfeld vor dem Krieg bei China
gemacht hat da kann man dann ja auch
noch mal zu Deals kommen danach was den
Wiederaufbau angeht also da sind ganz
viele Dinge die eine Rolle spielen aber
genau wie das Territorium verteilt ist
glaube nicht dass das Peking das
irgendeine Perspektive darauf gibt was
da besonders wünschenswert ist aber die
Frage was ist inakzeptabel für Russland
und wenn die krimin inakzeptabel für
Russland ist dann gehört das eben dazu
und wir sind Jugendliche noch mal genau
bei der Frage was sagt der
Außenpolitiker der Grünen
wann hat die Ukraine gewonnen
das hat die Ukraine zu definieren und
das ist die Antwort die sie von jedem
verantwortlichen Politiker kriegen dass
die letztendlich dann sagen kann hängt
von unserer Unterstützung ab und wir
haben unsere Unterstützung in einer
beispiellosen Form geleistet und wir
haben dabei klargestellt wir geben das
was wir geben können damit ihr euch
selbst verteidigen können und wir tun
nichts wo wir in eine direkte
militärische Auseinandersetzung mit
Russland reingetrieben wenn das ist die
Abwägung die gemacht wird und ich finde
dafür sind wir schon relativ weit
gekommen und wenn ich sehe was jetzt
passiert da mit den wo sie sagen das
sind keine Nadelstiche
ja es ist die Fortsetzung des
Erfolgsrezepts der Rückeroberung die die
Ukraine ja schon erreicht hat nämlich
die es waren erfolgreich weil man den
Rückraum unter anderem durch die
größeren Reichweiten der Artillerie die
aus Deutschland gekommen ist und Heimat
Raketen aus den USA wenn man auf diese
Weise die Russen daran hindern konnte
sozusagen nachzuziehen an der Stellung
genau das findet jetzt statt das ist die
Vorbereitung
es wird auf gar keinen Fall noch mal
eine so erfolgreiche Offensive werden
wie die aus dem Sommer des letzten
Jahres bei hakiv wenigstens sind sich da
die noch mal wir haben ich habe in dem
diesem Krieg so viele Prognosen von
Militärs und Menschen die sich für
Militärexperten gehalten haben gehört
und man kann sagen der obergroße Teil
war nicht zutreffen z.B ist diese
Offensive in der Form die im Sommer
stattgefunden hat von vielen jedenfalls
von den Diensten ist wir haben den
Russen viel Zeit gelassen und wir haben
gleichzeitig ganz viel dafür getan und
ganz viel geliefert dass die Ukraine
heute mit Panzern mit Artillerie und
ähnlichem ausgestattet sind deswegen
bleibe ich bei dem Satz es hat die
Ukraine zu entscheiden
wir müssen sie in eine Situation
reinbringen dass ein Ende dieses Krieges
nicht sozusagen ihn auf diktiert werden
nein ich glaube nicht dass das die
Ukraine alleine zu entscheiden hat denn
die Tatsache dass wir die Ukraine so
massiv unterstützt haben also dass der
Westen die NATO die Europäer die Ukraine
so massiv unterstützt haben haben wir
aus einem gewissen Interesse getan und
wenn wir sagen
ja es wir müssen eine Situation
erreichen dass wir nicht einen offenen
Konflikt im Kern Europas behalten also
dann haben wir im Prinzip eine
ostverhältnisse wenn wir jetzt praktisch
uns Ruhe erkaufen für falsche
Kompromisse also dass die die diese nein
aber trotzdem denke ich es ist nicht
eine Frage die alleine die Ukraine
entscheidet sondern es muss eine
Situation hergestellt sein das Russland
die Ukraine nicht mehr angreift dass die
Souveränität und Integrität der Ukraine
wieder hergestellt wird denn sonst haben
wir einen offenen Konflikt der immer
weitergehen wird und das kann nicht im
Interesse Europas sein deswegen glaube
ich
das ist alternativlos dass wir zu einer
Situation kommen das Russland
militärisch so weit in die Ecke
getrieben werden muss das Putin und ich
glaube man sollte nicht glauben dass ein
Frieden ohne Putin und möglich ist ich
glaube ein Frieden ist auch mit Putin
möglich und das müssen wir einfach
es hat schon gesagt dass er weiß wie
häufig das Argument der Atomraketen von
Wladimir Putin in den Mund genommen wird
und natürlich kann sich am Ende Putin
darauf auch zurückziehen dass er sie hat
wird dann in Zukunft
Europa danach trachten müssen wenn
hooches genau so atomar aufzurüsten wie
es ja beispielsweise die Idee von
Emmanuel macron ist
in Europa die Vereinigten Staaten
Großbritannien Frankreich
die Allianz also die NATO ist ja eine
Allianz mit nuklearen Fertigkeiten und
das hat auch geholfen den Frieden für so
viele Jahrzehnte aufrecht zu halten was
ganz wichtig ist ist wie wir auf die
vordauernden Drohungen aus Russland zur
Benutzung eine Nuklearwaffe reagieren
das ist sehr unverantwortlich für einen
dauerhaftes Mitglied des
UN-Sicherheitsrates beständig mit
Nuklearwaffen zu tun ich glaube das ist
natürlich ein gewisses Risiko gibt es
ist sehr gefährlich die haben Tausende
von Nuklearwaffen und ganz
offensichtlich schertes sie nicht wie
viele unschuldige sie töten würden aber
ich glaube nicht dass sie solche
Nuklearwaffen einsetzen würden ich
glaube sie sehen diese Nuklearwaffen nur
als nützlich wenn Sie sie nicht verdient